one of the things that really really
upsets me a lot of things upset me but
this substance is that the people who
are talking about poverty and what
should be done are the people who are
not are least likely to be affected so
we're talking about policymakers we're
talking about you know my colleagues
middle class people who are not worrying
about you know the lack their lack of
health care health insurance on their
not wage earner I mean hourly wage
earners so I feel like I'm also living
in a bubble right so have a very
comfortable life you know in a great
neighborhood great schools all the
things that I talked about in terms of
what works and so what that means is
that I also hear what people are saying
right so the conversation is oh you know
it's so bad why are people you know
walmart target best buy whatever store
don't open on those days right um you
know you're horrible your Scrooge or
this than the other and then I I'm like
that is such a classist thing to say
it's classes because if you're if you if
if you depend on an hourly wage and if
you and I did you know when I was
growing up and might so do my parents so
I know that people sometimes like to
work on the holidays because you get
paid time-and-a-half right so if you
close the store and I'm not able to work
and I depend on those hours and the
extra money to be able to provide for my
family and where does that put me so
there's like this whole you know moral
ground that I think people sort of take
without really thinking about well
what's the impact of the people and the
workers now if you were to say well
close the stores and pay the workers and
that's a different story but the idea
that will close the store because it's
the wrong it's you're being a Scrooge
everybody should be home with their
families doesn't really take into the
complex into consideration the complex
the complexity of people's lives for me
what's different is being inside of
those kind of conversations where people
are talking about what to be done or
poor people and all the policies and
then having lived it and knowing what
it's like on a day to day and knowing
the disconnect between what we're saying
works and what's what we're proposing
and the actual you know what's actually
happening in people's lives back that
that discrepancy
you